foreign
so I did this video on my YouTube
channel about a week ago and for some
reason it just blew up and people are
very interested in this idea with
mortgage interest rates being super high
right now and uh we had showed a stat
there in the very beginning at you know
January of 2022 it was like three
percent by May of 2022 it was 10 so
we've been seeing the spike in
adjustable rate mortgages and I want to
get your 10 percent
not the interest rate itself okay so I
wanted to cover this and I just watched
your real estate lesson Financial Peace
University where you cover a lot of
these mortgage traps but a lot of people
are going this might be my ticket to
home ownership Dave
and this article impacts what's going on
here it's your ticket to foreclosure
yeah arms have started to recover more
from more than a decade of disinterest
from both consumers and lenders they're
returning to the fold amid a sharp
increase in home prices and fixed
mortgage rates that began in early 2022
as the housing market begins to thaw
from a year of depressed demand more
potential sellers begin to list their
homes could arms help more prospective
buyers get a foot in the door of their
first home understand this this passive
aggressive question statement here is on
Experian
what is their vested interest in this
getting you in debt and keeping you in
debt because you're all worried about
their FICO score hello they'll make
money if you get a mortgage and they
have to run the score
this is a money-making scheme yeah we
love debt and so we're Experian and
we're gonna passively aggressively ask
is this a way for people to get their
foot in the door that sounded very soft
sounded like a suggestion to me sounded
like a conspiracy to me serious oh they
have a new stat in here Dave the share
increased from three percent it was for
the much of the decade to as high as 13
by October mortgages of the mortgage
Origins that are going out there three
percent used to be adjusted so 97 were
not doing adjustables and now 87 and
it's down as of April 2023 they say it's
now eight percent of all new mortgages
it's taking a dip so do we need to talk
about this well I want you to just share
why they're a bad idea because people
don't understand and there's a funny
clip from the office with Michael Scott
falling for one of these and he's like
well no it's a 30 and she's like no it's
10 over and so I wanted you just to run
the analysis on who is this for why are
people doing this why should they stay
away okay
um we'll get real technical to help you
but before we do that let's just say the
all right if you buy a mortgage that
adjusts
in an increasing interest rate
environment
what are you expecting it to adjust to
up well that's dumber than a rock on the
surface
interest rates are moving up and you're
buying a mortgage that allows them to in
and gives you the probability of a
higher interest rate later let's just
start with that's stupid
okay the second thing is this let's say
interest rates stay the same or go down
slightly
here's what you're going to discover
your mortgage interest on your
adjustable rate mortgage is going to go
up
even if rates go down a little or stay
the same
here's why your mortgage is adjusted
based on an index
and a spread over the index let's just
do a simplified version okay let's say
you took out a four percent adjustable
rate mortgage and it's supposed to be
two percent over the index that would
mean the index would be two
two plus two is four okay
and if the but the index however when
you start your brand new mortgage they
move you in on a bait and switch
because the index is already higher
would it would would give you the spread
would already give you a higher interest
rate today than you're getting today so
instead of the more okay let's say we're
getting a four percent adjustable rate
the index is two your spread is two so
that two plus two equals four okay but
it's not two the index today in that
case would be more like 2.6
um
so the interest rates would have to go
down 0.6 for your rate to remain the
same the next time it adjusts y'all
follow I'm doing this okay because the
index plus your spread equals your
interest rate and the index is already
cheated up when you go in so rates would
have to go down in order for you to do
this and so it's a big gamble so it's
not a big gamble 100 and dead on gonna
have an increase there's no gamble about
it you're you you know and you bought
the house on short-term thinking thank
God it's Friday oh God it's money I can
pay this payment like this payment's
even going to be around on the first
adjust you're going to see an increase
it's not a gamble almost a hundred
percent of the time because again rates
would have to go down to get your spread
to keep your spread on the end far
enough down okay it just doesn't work so
this all came from
mortgage companies protecting themselves
in 1982. I was selling real estate the
first adjustable rates came out then
okay because interest rates had gone to
17 percent
remember that and more and money market
rates back then we had these things
called savings and loans Money Market
rates on your savings were 12 percent
you could get 12 on your savings account
well let me help you with this the local
savings and loan makes a loan in the 70s
on a mortgage four percent
they are receiving four percent on a
hundred thousand dollars
interest rates shoot up that's a four
percent fixed rate loan
now in order to get a hundred thousand
dollars into the savings zone or into
the bank they got to pay out twelve but
they're only receiving four that's a
problem that's caught in the banking
World they call that disintermediation
your your butt's upside down
mathematically and so that's one of the
things called Savings and Loan industry
to crash that's why I brought up savings
loans it's one of the things that
crashed them was disintermediation it
wasn't fraud it was that
because they had millions of dollars of
mortgages on the books at a fixed rate
and all of a sudden they're having to
pay more than they're receiving to get
new savings deposits so they said to
themselves self I don't like this next
time these rates go up we're going to
have a portion of our portfolio that
adjusts up as interest rates go up and
so the adjustable rate mortgage was born
so that to protect the banks against an
increasing interest rate environment so
they don't get stuck with a bunch of low
interest mortgages on the books
the first and the first adjustable rate
mortgage I sold was the fixed rates were
14 1982 1983
the fixed rates were 14 our adjustables
were 12.
and I said man nobody will ever buy
these things and that was 1982 and
they're still buying them still around
today so just transferring the risk from
the lender onto you 100 what it does it
transfers the risk of higher interest
rates from the lender it ensures that
the lender is always going to freaking
make money
foreign this is a bank play it ain't got
anything to do with being a blessing to
you in allowing according to experience
help prospective buyers get their foot
in the door bull crap hadn't got
anything to do with prospective buyers
it's got to do with banks and one thing
you can count on banks is Banks
protecting Banks it's what they do and
they've been good at it for a long time
that's why their Furniture is nicer than
yours that's why their building is
bigger than yours
it's not an accident Santa Claus didn't
build those freaking Towers in the
skyline
it was you you built them with this kind
of crap where you give these Banks your
money you fall for the Trap of this
stuff so adjustable rate mortgages is
it's one of the biggest rip-offs ever to
come along especially because of the
motivation of it yeah it become an
inspiration everything so don't if you
have to do an adjustable rate mortgage
it means you can't afford the house